[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه مناصره الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
يقتحمون المحكمه العليا والكونغرس والقصر
الرئاسي بعد اسبوع على اداء لولا دا سيلفا
اليمين
روسيا تصاعد على اكثر من جبهه مناورات مع
بيلاروسيا برباط في الشرق وهجمه انتقاميه
تنفيها اوكرانيا
في يوم الانتقام الاحتجاجات من طهران الى
اوروبا وحقوقيون يحذرون من حمله ترهيب
للنظام عبر الاعدامات
[موسيقى]
بعد مفاجاتي وفضائح هاري بريطانيون يحدرون
من تداعيات الهجوم على العائله المالكه
واثاره الشكوك لدى الشعب
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
التي نبداوها من الاخبار العاجله التي
تاتي من البرازيل فقد اقتحم مئات من
مناصير الرئيس البرازيلي السابق زائر
بورتسونارو مقرات السلطات الرئيسيه في
البرازيليه ووقوع اشتباكات بين قوات الامن
واثار الرئيس السابق واقتحم انصاره
بولسنارو مبنى الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا
وقصر بلانالتو الرئاسي متسببين بالكثير من
الاضرار حسب ما تظهر صور متداوله على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه ويحتاجها هؤلاء
المتظاهرون على عوده
رئيسا للبرازيل الاسبوع الماضي بعد ما
تقدم على بونسون رؤوف الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الثلاثين من
اكتوبر الماضي في السياق تاكد مسؤولون ان
لويس انسيونا ده سيلفا هو موجود حاليا
منتجات
[تصفيق]
كازا
ومعنى الان الصحفي هاني الدرسان مباشره من
ساو باولو هاني اهلا بك معنا ما المعلومات
التي تمكنتها من جمعها خاصه في ظل وجود
الرئيس الجديد لولا دا سيلفا عندكم في ساو
باولو امام هذه الاحداث التي تحصل الان في
برازيليا
مساء الخير حضرتك
غير معلوم بالضبط مكان تواجد الرئيس
الاسد تعد لنا ذاكره الاحداث التي حصلت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كما فعل
المؤمن
الامريكيه التاريخ يعيد نفسه بعد سنوات
ومؤيدين الرئيس السابق
بصوا ماريو همم اعمال همم الصحف
البرازيليه قد عنوانت عنها بانها اعمال
وزيره الدفاع السيد الابيض قال بان
اعمالنا عبثيه واعمال
بشكل عام في البرازيل التجمعات الاحتجاجيه
هي ليست مخالفه للقانون ولكن الاعمال
التخريبيه التي الحق بالمراكز السياسيه
والمراكز الرئاسيه تعتبر مخالفه للقانون
ويعاقب عليها ايضا كانت التجمعات هي من
الاساس تحت دعوه
الحكم ولكن تطور
الدراما لتتحول الى اعمال اقتما لهذه
المراكز بشكل عذرا على المقاطعه ولكن صحيح
ما يحدث الان في برازيليا يعود الى
الاذهان صوره احداث الكابيتل بعد خساره
ترامب للانتخابات الرئاسيه امام جوبيد
ولكن همم في الولايات المتحده تم السيطره
على الموقف سريعا نشاهده من صور وطبعا
الذهاب الى القصر الرئاسي المحكمه العليا
ومبنى الكونجرس الاحداث تبدو خارج عن
السيطره بشكل كبير ما المعلومات المتوفره
عن همم موقف القوى الامنيه والجيش كذلك
همم وماذا قدرتهم على السيطره على الوضع
في برازيليا ام ان الموقف خرج عن السيطره
الموقف لم يخرج
ولكن هناك دائما تخوف غير معلب بوجود
تواطئ من بعض همم
سواء الشرطه او حتى من قبل همم رجال الجيش
فيما يتعلق بالضغط هذا ضبط هذا النوع من
الاحتجاجات طبعا هنالك جدا دي الرئيس
السابق لصناريو هو من خلفيه عسكريه همم
بشكل عام وايضا هناك له مؤيدين كثر داخل
ال- ال- الشرطه لكن همم ما يطمئن بشكل عام
البرازيلي هي دوله
يعني لو تم المحاوله من اقتحام او عمل اي
عمل من من عمليه انقلاب الدوله الدوله
قويه لها جذور
عند طيب قويه من الصعب ان يكون همم اكبر
مؤشر ربما في عمليات الانقلاب هي وسائل
الاعلام وسائل الاعلام البرازيليه كيف
تتعاطى مع هذه الاحداث الان هاني
طبعا وسائل الاعلام وسائل الاعلام
عناوين الصحف الكثيره التي صدرت الان ومن
خلال وسائل فصل اجتماعي تسمى هؤلاء
المشاركين في هذه الاعمال
السياسيين المصري
تحت اي مسمى كانت هذه الاعمال
الديمقراطيه والسياسيه والبيئه السياسيه
التي متواجده منذ سنوات الفرنسي
البرازيليون بشكل عام عانوا كثيرا من
الدكتاتوريه لسنوات كبيره وهم يرفضون اي
نوع من انواع الفرد القوه السياسيه او قوه
الراي على اي طرف سواء كان يمينا ذلك هناك
حاله من الخوف الان في الحقيقه لدى الشارع
البرازيلي يتحول فقط
على شاشه العربيه الان حزب العمال الذي
ينتمي اليها الرئيس البرازيلي سيلفا اذا
يطالب باحتواء مناصجه
اذا المشاهدين كمان متابع معكم في هذه
الصور الان على الشاشه قاموا باقتحام مبنى
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا والقصر الرئاسيه
في العاصمه البرازيليه طبعا احتجاجا على
خساره الرئيس السابق جائر بون سونارو
للانتخابات الرئاسيه امامنا سيلفا في
الانتخابات الاخيره هاني اعود اليك دعوات
الان لاحتواء هذه
الاحتجاجات او هذه كما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام
همم تصفها بالاعمال الارهابيه في البرازيل
همم ما هي ال- ال- السيناريوهات نحن الان
امام ماذا هل يعني سيكون هناك احتواء فعلا
للموقف حسب التقديرات ام همم لا ماذا تقول
التكهنات الان والسيناريوهات حول ما يحصل
الان في
الحقيقه
اما ان يتم احتواء هذا الامر من قبل
العقلاء داخل
القياده السياسيه في البرازيل وبالاخص من
قبل اليمنيين بخروجها من دعوه الناس
او يكون هنالك
اليمنيون هناك كثير منهم
كانوا يدعون الاستخدام القوه في حاله تصدر
هذا الامر تصدر هذا اتجاه المشهد العام تم
استخدام القوه سوف يكون هذا امر خطير جدا
على المستقبل السياسي في البلد شخصيا لا
اعتقد بان ال ال الاختيار سوف يتجه لتصعيد
فيما يتعلق في القوه ولكن دائما كان
الانصار الخاصين بيبوسوناريو يدعون الى
استخدامهم يختلفون
الرئيس
هاني مره اخرى الاخبار العاجله لا تنقطع
من البرازيل حزب رئيس البرازيلي يطالب
الادعاء العام بامر القوات الامن باحتواء
المتظاهرين قبل قليل بعض الصور كان لافتا
انه قوات الامن كانت تبدو يعني متفرج امام
ما يحصل من هذا الاقتحام هلا فسرت لنا
كذلك طبيعه همم العلاقه بين ادعاء العام
وقوات الامن وعلاقه القوى الامنيه كذلك
بيبوسونار وانصاره
لديه خلفيه عسكريه ولديه انصار كثر داخل
الشرطه والشرطه المدنيه والشرطه العسكريه
بالفعل هناك بعض تظهر بعض الامن وحتى
عناصر الامن يقومون بتصوير الاحتجاجات من
قبل من خلال جوالهم طبعا هنالك انصار
انصار ولكن لا اعتقد بان يكون هنالك ثواني
عن من قبلهم للدفاع عن الملكات العامه
تخريب الممتلكات العامه سوف يعتبر جريمه
اما التظاهر هو ليس جديد ولكن ما يحصل
الان هو بالفعل جريمه عمود طيب الالتحاق
بكثير والتخريب الذي يلحق بالممتلكات
العامه سواء في البلاص في في رئاسي او حتى
في البرلمان هذا الامر سوف يكون له تبيعات
كبيره جدا على الناحيه حتى التشريعيه فيما
يتعلق بالاحتجاجات ايضا هاني درسا شكرا
جزيلا لك سنقي عيوننا على تطورات الموقف
ايضا في برازيليا وما ستؤول اليه هذه
الاقتحامات من قبل انصار الرئيس البرازيلي
السابق
[موسيقى]
من البرازيل نذهب الى اوكرانيا لم ياتي
الرد سريعا لكنه جاء مدويا هكذا هي روسيا
عندما تريد الانتقام فبعد اكثر من اسبوع
على هجومي
اوكرانيا
روسيا كبد فيه اوكرانيا روسيا خسائر كبيره
في ارواح جنودها جاء الرد الروسي هجمه
انتقاميه قويه وجهتها موسكو بضربه صاروخيه
استهدفت مبنا في كراماتورك
اكثر من 600 جندي اوكرانيا وهذا طبعا بحسب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لنستمر
ردا على هجوم كيف ضد موقع مؤقت العسكريين
رؤوس قربى مكيفكا في دونتس نفذت القوات
الروسيه عمليه انتقاميه خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه اكتشفت المخابرات الروسيه نقاط
الانتشار المؤقته للقوات الاوكرانيه في
كراماتوس تضم مئات الجنود قتل منهم اكثر
من 600 جندي في هجوم صاروخين روسي مكثف
لكن كيف من جانبها نفس هذه الروايه
الروايه حول مقتل هذا العدد الكبير معتبره
انه دعايه الروسيه مبالغ فيها واكدت الا
ضحايا في الهجوم
وربما في اطار الانتقام الروسي كذلك كثفت
موسكو ضربتها الصاروخيه تحديدا في دمياط
في مختلف جبهات المعارك في اوكرانيا
والتطورات الميدانيه تتلاحق في ظل تعدد
جبهات القتال والتي لم تعد تتمركزوا في
نقطه بعينها بل باتت تشمل نقاط متعدده في
الشرق وفي الجنوب تبادل القصف بين
الجانبين لا يزال مستمرا بين رغبه الروسيه
في اختراق الحصون الاوكرانيه وطموح
اوكرانيا في استعاده الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها موسكو القتل الاشد حده يتمركز في
بلدتي بخمط وفوليدار على خط المواجهه في
دنيتك شرقا هذا وازداد الضغط الروسي حول
مدينه في سوليدار بعد ما قامت موسكو
بتعزيز قواتها هناك اما في الجنوب الشرقي
فان الوضع لا يبدو هادئا حيث يتواصل
التقدم والاكراني في منطقه
الروسيه الى تعزيز دفاعتها هناك تحسبا
لهجوم كبير من قواتك اما في خيرس ف وصلوا
الضربات الروسيه على المدينه التي استعادت
كيابه سيطره عليها قبل اسابيع
وفي خطوه لاعاده تمضع اقوى في المعركه
واصلت روسيا تعزيز قواتها في مختلف
الجبهات سواء من فرق خاصه مثل فاجنر او
فرق المجندين او غيرها اخذوا المستحقين
جنود القادمون من جمهوريه الشيشان وذلك
وفق ما اعلنا عنه رمضان قديره رئيس
جمهوريه الشيشان الاخير كشف عن ارسال 300
مقاتل من القوه الشيشانيه الخاصه المحترفه
للقتال في المهام الاكثر خطوره في دمبرز
[موسيقى]
معنى انا من ابو ظبي
اهلا بكم معنا في اخبار الساعه عن العربيه
لماذا تنفي اوكرانيا هذه الروايه الروسيه
مساء الخير يا مشاهدين الكرام ااا لانه
اوكرانيا ابدا ما طخ في ما يجري في ارض
المعركه واليوم حتى الصحفيين الغربيين
وصحبه صحفيين العرب الرجاء الى
مكان الحدث واثبت ان اخبار الروسيه عاريه
عن الصحه
الغربيين المراسلو
نقلوا انهم سمعوا على الاقل اربع انفجارات
قبل منتصف الليل في كلام موتورز
صحيح صحيح هو هو مؤكدوا ان الضربه يعني
كانت الضربه يعني في فكره موتورز ولكن لما
جاءوا الى مكان الحدث ما شافوا اي اثار
يعني الضحايا نعم هو شافوا اثار الضربه
الصاروخيه الروسيه ولكن ما شافوا اي اي
ادله او اي اي اثار يعني هذا يعني هذه
الكميه الضخمه يعني من من الاقراض
التي قالت مسك
يعني هذا يعني هم ما اكدوا يعني هذه
الضحايا طيب ااا فيما يتعلق بزاويه اخرى
طبعا الضربه الموجعه التي تلقتها روسيا في
ليله راس السنه في مكيفا ما تزال يقول
المحللون انها تحضر للرد عليها هي تتحضر
لما يشبه حرب مدن مع بيلاروسيا الجانب
الاوكراني كيف يتحضر امام هذه
السيناريوهات الان امام خاصه التحضير لحرب
المدن
اول نحن لا نعتبر هذا يعني
انتقام نحن منذ البدايه قلنا ان نحن سنفعل
كل شيء عشان تحرير ارضنا ومن بين هذه
الخطوات ضربه المكيه
واوكرانيا اضبطت عظمها وقدرتها على تحرير
ارضنا وطرد الاحتلال الروسي من من جميع
الاعراضنا
يعني في شمال ولا في شرق وفي جنوب
اوكرانيا في اخرصون
واليوم نحن نشوف كمان يعني تقدم همم
نحن همم اضبطنا قدرتنا على التعلم بشكل
سريع وفي استخدام الاسلحه
والمساعدات العسكريه التي نستلمها
حتى يعني عكس مؤشر همم
مؤشر باور يعني القوه العسكريه على قدم
الكبير لاوكران واليوم اوكرانيا تحتل
المرتب الخامس عشر عالميا في في القدره
العسكريه مقارنه بين المكان الثاني
والعشرين العام الماضي
على على ذكر ما ستؤول اليه هذه الحرب ارجو
ان تتفضل بالبقاء معي سنتوقف قليلا
مشاهدينا الان مع ترجيحات محللين او
عسكريين بطول امه هذه الحرب وسيناريوهاتها
المتوقع لمتابعه هذه السيناريوهات ونعود
للنقاش
اذا كما شاهدنا مشاهدينا في حرب اوكرانيا
منذ بدايه عام 2023 الايام الاولى من
العام الجديد تنبا باستمرار المعارك على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه فكل طرف يواصل تجهيز
قوته العسكريه على طريقته فبينما تعزيز
موسكو صفوفها بقوات اضافيه لا يزال الجيش
الاوكراني يراهن بشكل كبير على الاسلحه
الغربيه في هذا السياق اعتبرت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه ان الاسلحه
الجديده التي وعدت بها اوكرانيا تعد مؤشرا
واضحا على ان المواجهات مستمره لفتره ليست
بالقصير
والصحيفه خابت اكثر في الخطوه التي اتخذها
الحلفاء الغربيون بتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
النوعيه وما يحمله ذلك من دلالات الصحيفه
ورات في ذلك تاكيدا على تخطيط الحلفاء
الغربيين لاوكرانيا الى دعم الهجمات
الاوكرانيه وفضل الهجمات الروسيه كما ان
هذا الدعم يوحي الى رغبه كل من الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا والمانيا في تقديم دعم
اكثر فتكا للاوكرانيين هذا فضلا على ان
هذه الخطوه
تحمل او تلمح الى عدم رغبه معسكر الغربي
في الدخول في مفاوضات سلام مع روسيا على
المدى القريبه على الاقل وهو ما يفتح
الحرب على سيناريوهات
اذا نعود اليك سيد بطلي بدنيت في ابوظبي
يعني عده سيناريوهات بعد كل يعني هذا
التصعيد منذ بدايه هذه السنه 2023 من
بينها جمود خطاب خطوط القتال ااا سيكون
هناك حرب استنزاف همم اوكرانيا ستنتصر في
هذه الحرب او ربما سيكون هناك نصر روسي
دعني اتوقف معك مع السيناريو ال- ال-
النصر الاوكراني الى اي حد هذا السيناريو
يمكن ان يكون واقعيا في ظل همم قوه الجيش
الروسي وهو ثاني اقوى جيش في العالم
ان السيناري انتصار اوكرانيا هو السونار
الوحيد المحتمل يعني
من بين كل هذه السيناريوهات التي كنا
نتحدث يعني عنها لان اوكرانيا تصبح اكبر
اقوى يعني كل يوم عن طريق عظمها وقدرتها
عن طريق مساعدات العسكريه التي نستلمها من
شركاء يعني في العالم ومن جانب الاخر تصبح
روسيا ادعى يعني عسكريا كل يوم نعم انها
اليوم غير قادر على توفير كميه كافيه من
المعادلات العسكريه في جبهه القتال يعني
فقدت اكثر من ثلاثه
الدبابه وسته الاف المركبه المدرعه خلال
فتره هذه الحرب وفي همم لا تستطيع التوفير
مثل هذه الكميه مره اخرى
وان النتيجه الواضحه في هذه المعادله
انتصار اوكرانيا وخساره الروسيا وهذا مش
يعني شكل يعني هذا واضح بالنسبه لهذا
بالنسبه للمحللين همم في العالم نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك فيتا اللي بديانين دبلوماسيه
الاوكرانيه كنت معنا من ابو ظبي
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نعود مره اخرى الى البرازيل
وما يحصل فيها فنذكر اذا النبي الخبر
الاهم فيها اذا فقد اقتحم مئات من مناصير
الرئيس البرازيليه السابق زائر مقرات
السلطات الرئيسيه في برازيليه وقعت
اشتباكات بين قوات الامن والانصار الرئيس
السابق في اخر التطورات الادعاء العام فتح
تحقيقا ضد المتورطين في اقتحام هذه
المباني الحكوميه وقد اقتحم انفارب مبنى
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا
الرئاسي متسببين بالكثير من الاضرار حسب
صور متداوله على وسائل التواصل ويحتاج
هؤلاء المتظاهرون على عوده ايناسيونا دا
سيلفر رئيسا للبرازيل الاسبوع الماضي بعد
ما تقدم على بولو في الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في الثلاثين من
اكتوبر الماضي في السياق اكد مسؤولون ان
لويس سيلفا هو موجود حاليا في سوفاوله
الدستوريه رئيس البرازيل قبل اسبوع وصفتها
بنت امنيا مشدد اذا وكما نتابع في العاجل
الان رئيس مجلس الشيوخ البرازيليه يقول
انه تم حشد قوات الشرطه للسيطره على الوضع
في البرازيليا قبل ذلك كما ذكرت للدعاء
العام في البرازيل يفتح تحقيقا ضد
المتورطين في اقتحامات المباني الحكوميه
واا طبعا مناصره الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
بون سوناري يطالبون الجيش بالتدخل والغاء
نتائج الانتخابات اما وزير العدل السابق
في حكومه بونسونارو فيطالب الامن باستعاده
النظام في برازيليا اذا طبعا هي مشاهد كما
نتابع معكم همم من العاصمه البرازيليه
تعيد الى الاذهان مشهد اقتحام مبنى
الكابتل في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
انصار الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب عندما
خسر الانتخابات
الرئيس الامريكي في 2020 همم هناك من يشبه
المشهد اللي حصل الان في البرازيل ما حصل
في امريكا
كما نتابع معكم همم العديد من انصار
الرئيس الخاسر للانتخابات جائربون سونارو
اقتحموا هذه المقرات الحكوميه السلطات
الرئيسيه في همم البلاد اا ما ادى الى هذا
المشهد العالم في ظل غياب الرئيس عن
العاصمه بانتظار اذا ما ستؤول اليه هذه
الاحداث اذا كانت القوه الامنيه تتدخل اذا
كانت تحتوي الموقف ام ان الامور ستخرج عن
السيطره
[تصفيق]
موقع
قسطوان
ك يا باطن جيش طالع هكذا
خبر الساعه البرازيل بعد قليل مع ضيف
يتابع معنا كذلك اخر التطورات من هناك على
العموم نذهب الان الى فاصل في اخبار
الساعه ومن بعده نتابع كذلك الصين تودعوا
سياسه صفر كفيل بالغاء اخر قيود السفر
والعزله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ومتابع من ايران لغته
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات باتت السلاح
الوحيده المتاحه امام المتظاهرين في ظل
مواجهته لمواجهه قرارات الاعدام والاعتقال
التي تتخذها السلطات الايرانيه في كل يوم
واليوم رفع المحتاجون في المقابل زخم
التظاهرات تحت عنوان يوم الانتقام وذلك
ردا على اعدام شابين هما محمد مهدي هو
محمد حسين بتهمه قتل عضو
احتجاجات شارك فيها ايضا طلاب الجامعات من
بينهم طلاب جامعه طهران والتي تعرض الكثير
منهم للاعتقال واخرون مهددون بالاعدام
[موسيقى]
شو جابوني
عن صدور
ابنه الرئيس الاسباني
قد حكم عليها سابقا بالحب سته اشهر ومنعها
خمس سنوات من الانشطه السياسيه والثقافيه
لارتكابها جريمه النشاط الدعائي ضد النظام
على حد وصفاء وكانت سلطاته واوقاف في
سبتمبر الماضي بتهمه التحريض على
الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت وفاه سامي
الان كل ما يحدث في الداخلي والخارج كل
هذا بسبب ضعف حكومتنا وليس لاي منهم اي حل
لتعويض عن الوضع الراهن او لا يبدو انهم
قاده فاعلون وقادرون على قياده الدوله نحو
الاصلاح وحل الازمات لذا فعلوا ما يظهروا
قوتهم للتعويض عن هذا الضعف العميق
والغضب الداخليه
اشخاص على خلفيه دعوتهم الى الاضراب دعما
للاحتجاجات وتعد هذه المره الاولى التي
تعلم فيها السلطه القضائيه اصدار احكام
مرتبطه بتهمه من هذا القبيل منذ الاحتجاج
[موسيقى]
حالات الاعدام المرتبطه بالاحتجاجات باتت
لوحدها معضله حقيقيه تواجه المحتاجين وتبث
الرعب في نفوسهم سيما وانها تتم وسط
اجراءات قانونيه غير واضحه تقول صحيفه
واشنطن الامريكيه صحيفه نقلت عن المدير
التنفيذي لمركز حقوق الانسان في ايران هذه
غيني تاكيده ان عمليات الاعدام التي جرت
حتى الان لم تتم من خلال اجراءات قضائيه
بل على يد لجنه خارج القانون الموضوع لا
يتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث كشف ذاته المتحدث
ان المعتقلين يتعرضون في كثير من الاحيان
للتعذيب الجسديه والنفسي ويجبرون على
الاعتراف تحت التهديد كما اكد المدير
التنفيذي لمركز حقوق الانسان في ايران ان
السلطات الايرانيه تستخدم عمليات الاعدام
والقوه المميته من اجل ترهيب المتظاهرين
[موسيقى]
ونعود مره اخرى الى البرازيل وفي اخر
تطورات اقتحام مناصره الرئيس السابق
ومقرات السلطات الرئيسيه في البرازيليه
وقوع اشتباكات بين قوات الامن والانصار
الرئيس السابق اكد وزير العدل البرازيلي
اذا الان ان القوات الامن تتحرك من كافه
انحاء البلاد للسيطره على الوضع في
برازيليه كما فتح الادعاء العام تحقيقا ضد
المتورطين في اقتحام المباني
الان تتحرك من كافه انحاء البلاد اذا كما
ذكرت للسيطره على الوضع يقول وزير العدل
البرازيلي التذكير فقط مشاهدينا نحن امام
هذا المشهد في البرازيل بعد اقتحام انصار
الرئيس الخاسر للانتخابات
الرئاسي متسببينها بالكثير من الاضرار حسب
ما تظهر هذه الصور
اذا معنا الان مباشره من ساو باولو هن
الدرسان مره اخرى يعود الينا هاني مرحبا
بك يعني بعد هذه التصريحات من وزير العدل
وكذلك من مجلس الشيوخ البرازيلي الى اين
تتجه الامور
مساء الخير لحضرتك اول الساده المتابعين
قليل قد
ايه بمقر الرئاسي من السيطره على داخل
البناء وحولت بالفعل دفع المحتاجين الذين
استطاعوا خرق الجدار الامني وخلق الحواجز
والدخول داخل القصر من اخراج الى خارج
القصير اذا الاحتجاجات الان هي تدور في
حول المركز
الرئاسيزات
تلك المناطق الحساسه في القطاع السياسيه
همم
في وزاره كانت تتبع
هذه الحجاج
نعم اذا هنالك نعم كان في المقابل كان شيء
لافته انصار بوسونارو دعوا الجيش للتدخل
من اجل الغاء نتائج الانتخابات التي خسرها
همم يعني مرشحهم بولونارو هل هناك اي
معلومات عن موقف الجيش اذا ما يحصل
لحد اللحظه الجيش
يقف في موقف المتابع ليس له الجيش فقط في
الحفاظ على الاذن الخارجي
الواضحه التي يحاول الجيش من خلالها توصيل
حتى الان
لن يحاول التدخل في هذا الزراعه السياسيه
لم يتطور الى صراع همم استخدام قوه ما بين
طرف على حساب الطرف الاخر حتى انا الشرطه
البرازيليه الشرطه العسكريه المسؤوله عن
هذه المقررات لم تستخدم قوه نفقه الى حد
اللفظ وهذه طبعا تم تم من قبل المدعي
العام طلب فتح التحقيق اما ذكرتهم ولكن
هذه الاعداد الكبيره كانت
غير حتى افراد الامن الموجوده طيب هلا
ذكرت قبل قليل انه استجابه لهذه الاوامر
يبدو ان القوات الامن بدات بالتحرك لاخراج
مناصرين بو سونار ومن المقرات هل تعلم الى
اين وصلت العمليه هل نجحوا على الاقل في
اخراجهم من بعض المقرات ام ليس بعد
المقرر الرئاسي تم بتبقى طبعا تامر خرجه
من المقرر الرئاسي الكونغرس لم يتم تاكيد
الى حد اللحظه من خلوه من المتظاهرين ولكن
همم ما يوجد تاكيده هو وصول
يعني
طيب فقدنا الاتصال مع هاني على العموم
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات هذه
الدرسانكم معنا من ساو باولو
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نبقى في متابعه اذا الوضع في
البرازيل طيب
سنغلق اذا الان ملف البرازيل على موقع
عيوننا على ما ستطور اليه الامور هناك
نذهب الان الى بريطانيا حيث تواصل تسريبات
الامير هاري اثاره الجدل داخل بريطانيا
قياسا بنشراه الكبيره التي ابتسمت بها
سينما تلك المتعلقه بالعائله الملكيه
الاخيره كانت محور اتهامات صريحه وهجوم
واضح غير مسبوق العائله الملكيه من جانبها
التزمت الصمت حياه لهذه الاتهامات بينما
لم تتاخر الصحف البريطانيه في التعليق على
الموضوع بشكل يدين الامير هاري الى حد
كبير
في عنوانها لا احدا بمن ان عن مهمه في هذه
الوحشيه في تدمير الاسره اما صحيفه فقد
اعتمرت الا شيء يمكن ان يبرر المسار
الهدام والانتقام الذي اختاره الامير هاري
من جهتها رائد صحيفه ديلي مايلي لان هذه
نفسها اكبر قدر ممكن من السم في كتابه
الاميران ويليام هاري الشقيقان اللدودان
[موسيقى]
تسريبات هاري كشفت النقابه عن عداوه اتجاه
اخيه
لكن ويليام اختار تحملت
فهاري استهدف اخاه اكثر من مره
[موسيقى]
ويبدو بان الصمت ويليام سيتواصل
احد الاصدقاء المقربين لويليام اكد لصحيفه
ذا تايمز البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
ان الاميره لن يرد على اخيه حفاظا على
مصلحه العائله
لكن صمته يزيد من حجم الدرجه المثاره وحول
مدى صحه الاتهامات الموجهه اليه
و الاسود
في بريطانيا من احد افرادها وان كان اعتزل
منها وهو ما يعد سابقه تاريخيه وبهذا
الخصوص قال الخبير الدستوري في جامعه
صحفيه انه لا يعتقد انه بريطانيا سابقه
وشاهدت مثل من قبل القيامه احد افراد
العائله بمهاجمه المؤسسه بهذا القدر من
العلنيه واضاف انه اذا استمر الهجوم لمده
طويله فقط
والتفكير في تغيير رايهم في الملكيه وعما
اذا ينبغي اجراء اصلاح
في كل مره حاولت فيها القيام بذلك بخصوصيه
كانت هناك ايحاطات وتسريبات وخلق قصص ضد
زوجتي دراما ملكيه بامتياز بدات قبل سنوات
بطلها الامير البريطاني هاري وزوجته
الامريكيه ميغان هرب من قفص الملكيه بحثا
عن حريه يدعيان انهما سلبيا اياها ورغبه
منهما بالابتعاد عن الاضواء
الا ان ظهور الثنائيه ميكن وهاري بات اكثر
مما كان عليه عندما كان تحتسق في قصر
باكينغام احدها كان مع برنامج
دفاع من مصر
هاريم منفردا او برفقه ميجا كانت تدور
معظمها حول كواليس حياتهما السابقه
ادلى خلالها الثنائي بتسريحات الناريه
عزازه الفجوه بينهما وبين العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه التي يزعم هاري بانهم استخدموا
وسائل الاعلام ضدهما
المثير للسخريه هنا هو طرح مذكرات الامير
هاري للبيت قبل الموعد الرسمي لنشرها
مذكرات تضمنت مزاعم جديده عن الخلاف
والشقاق داخل العائله المالك البريطانيه
واتهامات وجهها الامير هاري لشقيقه ولي
العهد البريطاني واليمن بالتعدي الجسدي
عليه حسب ما نقلته صحيفه عن تسريبات
الكتاب التي تقول ان الامير واليمن
ووريث العرش وشقيقه هاري الاكبر اوقع اخاه
ارضا في شجار
كما ان هاري زعم ايضا ان شقيقه وليم تطاول
لفظيا على ميجا واصفا اياها بالصعبه
والوقحاء والمزيفه
الشهره التي اكتسبها هاري وميغن منذ ان
تخليا عن واجباتهما الملكيه في عام 2020
بدات ترتد عليهما بالعكس حسب استطلاعات
للراي فالكثير من البريطانيين ذاقوا ذرعا
بملو دراما العائله المالكيه برمتها وان
الكشف عن مزيد من المفاجات لن يغير ارائهم
سواء متعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته ميجان ماركل
او تلك المنتقدتها لهما
روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم
وضعت الصين
لثلاث سنوات من العزله بسبب الوباء فرفعت
الحجر الصحي الالزاميه للمسافرين القادمين
من الخارج
عادت فتح الحدود رسميه قرارا مفاجاه
اتخذته الصين في وقت تواجه فيه البلاد
موجه وبئيه جديده سريعه لانتشار وربما
الاسود في بعض المناطق وهذه المفارقه التي
رايناها في الصوره الاخيره بفرحه السفر
للصينيين بلا قيود وهذه الصوره لتكدس
المصابين بكرونا في المستشفيات وهو ما اثر
مخاوف عالميه سيما في ظل اجراءات احترازيه
اتخذتها عده دول بفرض قيود على القادمين
من الصين وفور القرار بفتح الحدود باشر
مئات الصينيين بالعبور بين هونغ كونغ
والبر الرئيسي للصين بعد اعلان رفع قيود
السفر كما تم السماحه نحو 60,000 شخص
بالسفر يوميا بين هونغ كونغ والبر الرئيسي
للصين فيما ينوي اكثر من 400,000 شخصين
السفر الى الشمال خلال الاسابيع الثمانيه
المقبله وتطالب السلطات المسافرين بتقديم
الدليل على اجراء اختبار
حديثه سلبيه
سعيده للغايه منذ اليوم الاول حجزت تذكره
واخبرت عائلتي بالقدوم كانوا سعداء جدا
وهم يتطلعون
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه نتبعه هذه الصور التي تظهر
لحظه اقتحام اثار رئيس البرازيليه السابقه
لمبنى الكونجرس وقصر الرئاسه في برازيليا
هذا المساء
والاقتحام شهيد اشتباكات بين قوات الامن
والانصار بوتونارو فيما تحركت قوات الشرطه
من كافه انحاء البلاد للسيطره على الوضع
شاهد
[تصفيق]
موقع
كاس العرب
روسيا تصاعد على اكثر من جبهه مناورات مع
بلا روسيا ضربات في الشرق وهجمه انتقاميه
تنفيها اوكرانيا
في يوم الانتقام الاحتجاجات من طهران الى
اوروبا وحقوقيون يحذرون من حمله ترهيب
للنظام عبر الاعدامات
بعد مفاجات وفضائح هاري بريطانيون يحذرون
من تداعيات الهجوم على العائله المالكه
واثاره الشكوك لدى الشعب
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه دوت نت على صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]